>>> NEW POLICE BODY CAMERA
FOOTAGE REVEALS GABBY PETITO
TOLD A UTAH POLICE OFFICER THAT
HER FIANCEE, BRIAN LAUNDRIE, HIT
HER DURING AN ARGUMENT.
IN PREVIOUSLY RELEASED BODY CAM
VIDEO, PETITO ONLY SAID SHE HIT
LAUNDRIE AND TOOK THE BLAME FOR
THE FIGHT.
THIS NEW REPORTING CORROBORATES
THE WITNESSES WHO CALLED 911 AND
THAT THEY TOLD POLICE.
CNN'S NADIA ROMERO LIVE IN NORTH
PORT, FLORIDA, WITH THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT DEVELOPMENT, NADIA.
>> Reporter: YEAH, JOHN.
THIS GIVES US MORE INSIGHT NOT
ONLY INTO THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN GABBY PETITO AND BRIAN
LAUNDRIE BUT WHAT HAPPENED ON
AUGUST 12th, JUST TWO WEEKS
BEFORE WE KNOW THAT THIS STORY
REALLY DEVELOPED.
THE LAST TIME SHE WAS SEEN IN
SALT LAKE CITY.
POLICE CAN'T FIND BRIAN LAUNDRIE
WHO MAY HAVE THE ANSWERS.
NOW WE ARE SEEING MORE OF A
COMPLETE PICTURE OF THAT AUGUST
12th DOMESTIC DISPUTE WHERE
GABBY PETITO SEEMS TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
ALTERCATION BETWEEN PETITO AND
LAUNDRIE.
LISTEN TO THE EXCHANGE BETWEEN
GABBY PETITO AND ONE OF THE
OFFERS ON SCENE.
>> IS THERE SOMETHING ON YOUR
CHEEK HERE?
IT LOOKS LIKE -- DID YOU GET HIT
IN THE FACE?
IT KIND OF LOOKS LIKE SOMEONE
HIT YOU IN THE FACE AND OVER ON
YOUR ARM, YOUR SHOULDER RIGHT
HERE?
THAT'S NEW?
KIND OF A NEW MARK?
>> YEAH, I DON'T KNOW.
>> CAN I SEE THE OTHER SIDE OF
YOUR FACE?
SO WHAT HAPPENED HERE AND HERE?
>> I'M NOT SURE.
HE WAS JUST TRYING TO GET BACK
IN THE CAR, AND THE BACKPACK GOT
ME.
.
>> SO THE BACKPACK GOT YOU?
THERE'S TWO PEOPLE CAME TO US
AND SAYING THEY SAW HIM HIT YOU,
PUNCH YOU.
JUST INDEPENDENT WITNESSES BY
MOON FLOWER.
>> I HIT HIM FIRST.
>> WHERE DID YOU HIT HIM?
>> I SLAPPED HIM.
>> YOU SLAPPED HIM FIRST ON HIS
FACE.
>> HE TOLD ME TO SHUT UP.
.
>> HOW MANY TIMES DID YOU SLAP
HIM?
.
>> A COUPLE.
>> AND HIS REACTION WAS TO DO
WHAT?
>> GRABBED ME.
.
>> HE JUST GRABBED YOU?
>> YEAH.
>> DID HE HIT YOU, THOUGH?
IT'S OKAY IF YOU ARE SAYING YOU
HIT HIM.
WE WANT TO KNOW THE TRUTH IF HE
HIT YOU.
I GUESS, YEAH.
BUT I HIT HIM FIRST.
>> WHERE DID HE HIT YOU? DON'T
WORRY.
JUST BE HONEST.
>> HE GRABBED MISS FACE, I
GUESS.
HE DIDN'T HIT ME IN THE FACE.
HE DIDN'T PUNCH ME IN THE FACE
OR ANYTHING.
>> DID HE SLAP YOUR FACE.
>> LIKE HE GRABBED ME WITH HIS
NAIL.
I WAS DEFINITELY CUT RIGHT HERE
BECAUSE I CAN FEEL IT.
IT REALLY BURNS.
>> SO THERE YOU HEARD THE POLICE
OFFICER ASKING GABBY MORE AND
MORE QUESTIONS, TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED THAT
LED UP TO A WITNESS CALLING
POLICE.
AND WE HEAR MORE ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN THAT COMPLETE
PICTURE FROM THE BODY CAM VIDEO.
NOW, UTAH IS ONE OF ABOUT 20
STATES WHERE IF THEY ARRIVE TO A
DOMESTIC DISPUTE, SOMEONE IS
SUPPOSED TO BE ARRESTED IF THEY
HAVE PROBABLE CAUSE.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN IN THIS CASE.
INSTEAD, THE TWO WERE SEPARATED
AND POLICE DROVE BRIAN LAUNDRIE
TO A HOTEL FOR THE NIGHT SO THE
TWO COULD COOL OFF.
NOW, THAT HAS COME UNDER AN
INVESTIGATION.
THERE IS AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION INTO HOW THE MOAB
POLICE OFFICERS HANDLED THAT
SITUATION.
WE ARE LEARNING MORE ABOUT
AUGUST 12th.
NOW WE ARE HERE IN FLORIDA WHERE
BRIAN LAUNDRIE LIVED WITH HIS
PARENTS JUST BEHIND ME.
YESTERDAY THE FBI CAME TO THE
HOUSE TO GATHER MORE EVIDENCE
USED BY CANINE UNITS TO FIND
BRIAN.
THERE IS AN ONGOING SEVEN FOR
HIM, NOT FOR THE DEATH OF GABBY
PETITO, TO BE CLEAR, BUT FOR
ACTIONS THAT HAPPENED WHEN THE
TWO SEPARATED, WHEN BRIAN WAS
ALLEGEDLY USING DEVICES AND A
DEBIT CARD THAT DID NOT BELONG
TO HIM.
THAT'S WHAT THE SEARCH WARRANT
IS FOR.
AGAIN, THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
FIND BRIAN LAUNDRIE.
HE'S BEEN MISSING, THE PARENTS
SAY THEY HAVEN'T SEEN OR HEARD
FROM HIM IN ABOUT TWO WEEKS.
SO THAT SEVEN IS STILL ONGOING.
JOHN.
.
>> NADIA ROMERO, THANK YOU FOR
THAT REPORT.
IT RAISES SO MANY QUESTIONS.
THE FORMER BALTIMORE CITY DEPUTY
POLICE COMMISSIONER.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
THAT BODY CAM VIDEO IS
HEARTBREAKING.
WE HEARD HER SAY, YEAH, HE HIT
ME BUT I HIT HIM FIRST.
IT'S ALL OF THIS SELF-BLAME THAT
WE SEE SO OFTEN IN DOMESTIC
ABUSE CASES.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT IS HEARTBREAKING VIDEO.
WHAT I'M SEEING NOW IS THE COPS
TOTALLY BLEW THAT CALL.
THERE WAS ENOUGH PROBABLE CAUSE
THERE, IN MY OPINION, TO MAKE AN
ARREST OF MR. LAUNDRIE.
YOU HAD WITNESS STATEMENTS, YOU
HAD THE PHYSICAL EVIDENCE, YOU
HAD THEIR STATEMENTS.
THERE WAS ENOUGH TO MAKE AN
ARREST.
WE ALSO SEE LAUNDRIE DO WHAT
MANY AGGRESSORS IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE DO, AND THAT'S TO PLAY
CALM AND COOL, NONCOMBATIVE,
YEAH, YOU KNOW HOW IT IS.
I'M JUST TRYING TO DEAL WITH
THIS CRAZY WOMAN.
AND THEY FELL FOR IT.
AND THEY STARTED TO SING ALONG
TO HIS TUNE.
AND IT'S REALLY DISTURBING WHAT
WE SAW.
AND TO THINK THAT MANY OTHERS
WHO HAVE GONE THROUGH THIS ARE
GETTING THIS TYPE OF RESPONSE IS
TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE IN POLICING
TODAY.
.
>> WE KNOW THE FBI BACK IN THE
HOUSE OF BRIAN LAUNDRIE OVER THE
LAST 24 HOURS.
WHAT COULD THAT BE ABOUT?
>> WELL, IT COULD BE A
COLLECTION OF MORE EVIDENCE.
MAYBE THERE WAS SOMETHING THEY
SHOULD HAVE RETRIEVED THE FIRST
TIME IN AND THEY DIDN'T.
MAYBE THEY WANT TO GET SOME
PERSONAL CLOTHING, ET CETERA, TO
FRESHEN UP THE SCENT FOR THE
DOGS.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS, YOU CAN'T
KEEP GOING BACK OVER AND OVER
AGAIN TO THE SAME SCENE BECAUSE
EACH TIME YOU LEAVE OUT OF THAT
DWELLING SOMETHING COULD CHANGE.
CLOTHES COULD HAVE BEEN WASHED,
THINGS DISCARDED.
SO WE REALLY NEED TO KNOW WHAT
WE'RE GOING IN FOR.
GET IT AND LIVE.
>> FINALLY, ANOTHER INTERESTING
PIECE OF EVIDENCE, MAYBE A
CONFUSING PIECE OF EVIDENCE, THE
FACT THAT ALL OF THESE CALLS
CAME IN AROUND THE TIME OF GABBY
PETITO'S DISAPPEARANCE RELATING
TO THE BRIAN LAUNDRIE RESIDENCE
IN FLORIDA.
WHAT DOES THIS ALL MEAN?
>> I REALLY WOULD NEED TO KNOW
WHAT WAS THE TEXT OF THE CALLS.
WHAT HAPPENED?
WHAT OFFICERS RESPONDED?
WHAT SUPERVISORS RESPONDED.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THESE CALLS
COMING IN, AND IT SEEMS AS IF
THE POLICE DID NOT TAKE THE TIME
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING ON.
WHY DO I SAY THAT?
BECAUSE THE CALLS KEPT COMING
IN.
WE NEED TO PULL THAT, GET INTO
IT, AND FIGURE OUT WHAT WAS
GOING ON WITH THESE CALLS.
IS THERE ANY TYPE OF STATEMENTS
IN THESE CALLS THAT COULD HELP
THE POLICE, COULD HELP THE FB
AT THIS TIME?
I DON'T KNOW.
WE DON'T KNOW.
IT IS IMPORTANT, AND IT SHOULD
NOT BE DISMISSED AS SUCH.
>> WHAT DOES YOUR GUT TELL YOU
THIS MORNING IS, ARE THERE ANY
CLOSER TO FINDING BRIAN
LAUNDRIE?
>> OH, I -- I THINK THE WAY THAT
THE FEDS WORK, THEY'RE VERY
METHODICAL.
SO I STILL HAVE FAITH IN THEM.
I HAVE FAITH IN ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT IS INVOLVED IN
THIS SEARCH.
BUT, Y